all right guys today i'm going to be
taking you through
a day in my life in the uk
a little overview this is where i live
the dorms are those like round houses
over there i don't live in the door
this is
the university like center at sunset
let me in wait
oh here
oh it's slide i'm just like where are
they
there's a door over there
[Music]
okay guys my friend gabby got here
hello we're gonna kill this workout
probably not it'll probably be average
[Music]
that's actually pretty nice so this week
i bought a meat
a meat thingy
throw in some olive oil
i'm
pepper gonna like my favorite spice okay
so garlic okay this is what we got now
all right guys this is the english
subway
we're going to the winter wonderland is
it called
yeah was it your idea say hi uh no it
wasn't my idea but hi
we still got american look we got
wingstop
kfc starbucks
burger king
yeah cupcakes
starbucks in the uk okay um show it
i just bought it oh wait here's the
santa
it fits perfect with our christmas sleep
tonight okay what is the worst date
you've ever been on
oh
that's a good question
um
okay i went on this one day with a guy
and it was like
he left his number for me on my last day
as a waitress and we went mini golfing
i had to pick him up
which i should have not gone but
whatever and then we got there and he we
went to buffalo wild wings but we went
mini golfing and he kept doing this
awkward thinking and high five he like
wanted to hold my hand but he was
nervous because they're too pretty give
me your hand it was like a
like a weird every time for mini golf it
was so odd and then we never talked
again but i got free buffalo
gabby worst date you've ever been on
oh i have a very expensive one so it was
like my ex-boyfriend's friend who's
petty i was trying to attack
and we went to go see that
what's that movie
that it's like
this girl's a fashion designer and
there's an alien invasion and she's
trapped in someone's basement and then
he ends up like
it actually hits the end of the world
and she's stuck there
but like because she doesn't believe him
which then she leaves and then
red flag
oh
got the vibes all i have to say his name
is frank
we go on the date and like
we're sitting there in the movie and
like i'm not interested i was like you
do not look like your instagram pictures
like i was trying to be petty and like
it's it's karma is getting to me right
now and he just keeps like
and i was just like or just trying to
hold my hand and i'd be like and then he
like the look away
what got in my car and just we sat there
for like an hour this is great you're
probably like when are you leaving yeah
it was very good okay wait okay have you
ever have you ever had an nba player in
your dms
an nba player yeah
i'm honored that you asked me that
question though but no i've never had
the famous person that you have i have
dated more nba players than i can say
because i've signed ideas
yeah i also used to be cuter because i
used to be skinnier
when i was younger but they didn't care
that i was shocked
shut up with that you used to be cuter
because you're skinnier i wasn't
beautiful
no it's just something else it's just
effective
like you're prettier when you're skinny
yeah i'm not i'm not offended i feel
i mean maybe if you're underweight but i
was never underweight
you put me on medication to gain weight
though
why does she lie to us
she caps you guys can have someone what
does that mean
lies
i do not lie
you don't even know what else i said you
don't even know what i looked like in
high school
i don't but i feel like also here's the
thing it doesn't in my nose listen in my
opinion weight like you can always lose
weight weight is not permanent like
you're if your face is ugly
yeah
here's my pretty face you can always
lose weight
with no i have beef with the like what
you both just said of women feeling like
they are prettier when they're scared
yes because that's how society makes me
feel society sucks yes it does but like
i don't feel like by saying like society
sucks it makes it untrue
we both know you would not be as cute if
you gained a hundred pounds
it depends
some people gain weight in like the
right places but that's like that's not
the norm like most people don't have i
lost my gut
and
well the guts always i've accepted i
love it if my gut went to my ass
that's how my weight goes unnatural i
can't
size models how many plus size models do
you really see that don't have they have
a natural hourglass but like they're not
even like like potatoes
like i'm saying all this but it also
used to be severely underweight anorexic
like
severely so i can't i can say that i'm
happier now yeah being bigger well you
can say you could say it's not
everything yeah like it's not everything
i'm genuinely happier than i was when i
was thinner but like when i was thinner
it was more like
you more attention
yeah i have things to do it's like i
know you know
guys this homeless man just started
yelling at us
like a party man wait what did he say he
was you you were talking too much always
but
you guys are talking
about you were american thank you so
much thank you wait what did he say he
was like talking about how we were
american and stuff and i was like
oh these birds are not afraid of
anything bro you see this
like why aren't you afraid
i have no idea what this is i think it's
like lights or something but
i'm down i'm
ready i'm not even gonna lie this is too
cold to enjoy it's very close for the
christians out there
uh hagrid no
walking in a winter wonderland
[Music]
she's the best she's been helping us out
[Music]
[Music]
you just squeeze it yeah
ooh
i know isn't that convenient
okay i wish i videoed this earlier but
on the way in
they tell us that
our bottle our butt that we can get our
bottle on the way out and now it's gone
and on top of that that lady over there
told me to [ __ ] off so now
i am normally not this person either but
i'm going to be a girl well because they
shouldn't because they bought it too
yeah i don't know who you spoke to
earlier was it mark it was mark because
mark left at half past nine and i don't
know anything about this this particular
situation you know i mean
it was like a full bottle and he was
like if you come back at the end of the
night you can get it back we don't drink
were we bamboozled
you tell the lady not to tell me to [ __ ]
off next time that was quite rude
it's right there the lady in the like
right there on the left and the yellow
can you give us like a bathroom for free
shots at least next time we come in
i am not even this person but i'm mad
because it was the third time i'm not
mad how they smoked it was brand new and
you don't you know
but at the same time your employees
should not tell her [ __ ] off what said
about that
that's not that's uncalled for i'm sorry
i understand
but that language should not be used
when we are gonna hold them up no
i have a question what's the worst date
you've ever been on the last date yeah
mcdonald's did he pay at least yes
anything else happened um
i had [ __ ] preferred home
that's how boring that was i've got
[ __ ]
what's the most uk candy you have
yeah like
if i wanted to tell people i went to the
uk
and bought some candy
so we got this
[Music]
and this
what's your name
bro i asked the shopkeeper what to get i
said what what in the uk like what's uk
candy
he gives me this chocolate right
it was 24 pounds what the [ __ ]
should i get
what one should i get